as you can see the world is deep inside
Palestinian territory it's not sitting
on the internationally recognized
borders
most people who come to Jerusalem
usually they come through Israeli
tourist agencies and the Israeli
Ministry of Tourism they stay in Israeli
hotels they go with Israeli buses to
sites that the Israeli agencies decide
for them this means that they hardly
ever get exposed to the Palestinian
reality in Jerusalem
usually the first part of the duel is
devastating because they're exposed to
very harsh realities Israeli policies of
displacement and dispossession and so
the first thing they say the first
reaction is wow I didn't know
we've heard from both Israeli Jews as
well as Palestinians had heard two very
different descriptions of reality one of
the differences that we had presented to
us is the assumption that Israeli Jews
and Palestinians have the same rights
under the law and we know that not to be
the reality we've seen that